tres dedos al aire la insignia de las
protestas como despedida final continúa
los funerales por los más de 100
asesinados durante las manifestaciones
prodemocráticas del fin de semana en
mianmar la jornada más violenta desde
que comenzó la represión de la junta
militar
mi querido hijo nos dejas como deseabas
las fuerzas de seguridad no serán
perdonadas hasta el final rezo para que
nuestro pueblo de mi alma logre la
victoria que tú deseabas tu deseo se
cumplirá
la brutalidad del tal mató un ejército
birmano desde el golpe de estado del 1
de febrero ha matado a más de 500
personas y unas 2500 están detenidas una
deriva violenta que no parece amainar a
pesar de las múltiples condenas
internacionales los birmanos iban
saliendo a las calles de todo el país en
medio de un clima de terror una
situación que ha llevado a los grupos
étnicos armados como el ejército de
arakan y sus dos grupos asociados en la
alianza de la hermandad a unir sus
fuerzas amenazando con reanudar su lucha
contra los militares y no cesan las
matanzas de civiles un nuevo giro que
podría degenerar en una guerra civil el
portavoz del ejército de arakan acá en
tu acá dijo a the irrawaddy que es hora
de que las organizaciones étnicas se
unan para proteger a los civiles
oprimidos del régimen militar debemos
hacer nuestro mejor esfuerzo para
proteger las vidas y propiedades de las
personas oprimidas dijo los recientes
ataques aéreos durante el fin de semana
sobre la minoría étnica karen la más
antigua del país y los enfrentamientos
entre el taimado y la guerrilla de la
unión nacional karen que acordó una alta
el fuego con el gobierno en 2012 han
provocado un éxodo masivo hacia
tailandia
a más de 3000 hermanos están intentando
cruzar la porosa frontera